Hey guys, hope you guys are doing well.
This is the very first video of the course update.
In this video, I will teach you about different variations of autoblocks and how we can use
them.
In my last couple of videos on YouTube, you might have noticed that I've been using autoblocks
in a different way.
I'm not using it because they work better than the method that I've taught before.
I'm just using it because it's quite simple and it's good for my psychology.
So as you know, this is the old method, excuse me, so this is the old method, right?
You have lower, lower, lower, lower, lower, then you have a market structure shift, right?
And you have a free body gap here, as I have denoted here, as you can see, free body gap.
So most of the time we use the first candle of the free body gap as our autoblock, right?
You guys must know that because I have taught this before in my course videos and as well
on YouTube.
Now this right here is you have lower low, lower high, lower low, and then market structure
shift.
And now these consecutive bearish candles are your autoblock or is your autoblock, right?
So over here you can see we have used the first candle of the free body gap as our autoblock.
Over here you can see we have lower low, lower high, lower low.
So this consecutive candles in this last lower low before market structure shift is your autoblock.
Now nowadays for autoblock strategy, I'm using this as my autoblock, you know, and for
other strategies I use this.
Now what are the pros and cons of both of these methods, right?
This right here is a refined autoblock, okay?
And this is not a refined autoblock.
You are going to miss entries when you are going to trade this autoblock, okay?
So let's say price comes back into this level.
It's not going to happen all the time.
Whatever the chances that price comes back and mitigates this autoblock right here and
then goes back up is higher than the chances of this autoblock, okay?
You're going to have a greater risk reward when you take your entry from this level,
from this autoblock, and you're going to have a lower risk reward if you take your entry
from this.
So I take my entry from this.
Another thing, when you have this type of autoblock, the fair value gap is not necessary
in this leg, okay?
All you need is these consecutive candles, or it could just be a single candle, okay?
It could just be a single candle like that, okay?
It doesn't have to be one or two, but if they're like, let's say, as I said before, if they're
like two candles like that, yeah, then that could be, you can take your entry from here
or if you want to refine it, of course you can take it from here, but it is going to
decrease, it's going to decrease the chances of you getting triggered in the trade, okay?
So now here's the high probability setup for this setup right here.
When you have like a breaker block in alignment with this autoblock, that is a high probability
trade setup.
What is a breaker block?
You have lower low, lower high, lower low, the candle over here, the first candle of
this lower low, you know, it's going to be here.
If it is in alignment, let's, the size is the same, right?
And that, to me, is a high probability setup.
And then what's going to happen, price is going to tap into this autoblock and you're
going to have a push like that.
The reason why I go one to two with this type of setup is because you don't want to trust
the price to keep going higher, okay?
I just take my one to two and then I'm out the markets.
This right here is a refined entry.
So when you get an entry from here, that is like, it's going to give you more risk reward.
That's really that simple.
Yeah.
So, yeah, that's about it guys.
So you can use both of these autoblocks.
You don't have to be confused about which one to use.
It really comes down to your style of trading.
I am mostly trading this autoblock nowadays and this is what ICT teaches, this consecutive
bearish candles or a bearish, last bearish candle before the move to the upside that
breaks the structure.
But it's really up to you.
This one works as well.
And this is what I've been trading like most of my life and it works absolutely well.
Only downside, you're going to miss trades.
So it's really up to you now if you want to trade this one or this one.
This one has one pro.
You don't need to see a fair value gap, okay?
You can simply trade off this level, okay?
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to give you a couple of examples of this thing right
here.
You guys already know this, right?
So I'm going to give you an example of this one, this autoblock example.